vamos a imaginar que tenemos una gran
nube de átomos de hidrógeno que están
flotando en el espacio y cuando digo una
nube grande me refiero a que es grande
en tamaño y en masa en donde si
juntáramos la masa de todos estos átomos
tendríamos una nube enorme nosotros
sabemos que la gravedad hace que los
átomos de hecho se atraigan mutuamente
aunque uno normalmente no piensa en la
gravedad de átomos pero poco a poco los
afectaría poco a poco haría que se
acercaran unos a otros haciendo que se
condensen y poco a poco
atrayendo los hacia el centro de masa de
la nube moviendo todos los átomos poco a
poco si aceleramos el paso del tiempo
veríamos que esta nube se hace cada vez
más densa los átomos van a estar mucho
más cerca unos de otros
hasta que estos átomos de hidrógeno
empezarán a golpearse entre ellos y a
interactuar volviéndose todo esto cada
vez más denso recuerden que es una masa
muy grande de átomos de hidrógeno por lo
tanto la temperatura va a aumentar
la temperatura aumenta y siguen
condensándose y se siguen comenzando
hasta que algo bastante interesante
sucede vamos a ver que aquí ellas
también densas están todos los átomos de
hidrógeno apelmazados unos con otros
está bastante denso aquí en el centro no
puedo dibujar todos los átomos de
hidrógeno aquí es sólo para darles una
idea pero en ese momento va a haber una
presión interna muy grande causada por
la gravedad que está causada por toda
esta masa concentrada en el centro de
masa de nuestra nube en este momento la
temperatura se aproxima a los 10
millones de grados kelvin y en este
punto algo extraordinario sucede vamos a
recordar cómo luce un átomo de hidrógeno
y es más vamos a enfocarnos en el núcleo
del átomo de hidrógeno el núcleo del
átomo es un protón aquí afuera y un
electrón
que está dando vueltas alrededor del
núcleo y vamos a dibujar aquí otro átomo
de hidrógeno tengan en mente que esta
distancia no esta escala igual esta
distancia tampoco esta escala el núcleo
de los átomos es de hecho muchísimo más
pequeño que el radio del núcleo al
electrón pero bueno esto es sólo para
darles una idea sabemos que por las
fuerzas electromagnéticas que estas dos
partículas cargadas positivamente no
querrán acercarse entre ellas pero lo
que sabemos de lo que aprendimos sobre
la fuerza fuerte es que si llegaran a
acercarse lo suficiente bajo alguna
temperatura o presión muy muy muy grande
podríamos acercar estos dos protones lo
suficiente para que la fuerza fuerte
supere la fuerza de rechazo
electromagnética para que estos dos
núcleos de hecho se fusionen pues
justamente eso es lo que sucede cuando
se alcanzan temperaturas tan grandes
como la que está en este centro de masa
tenemos
la temperatura y presión suficientes
para superar estas fuerzas
electromagnéticas y acerca de estos
protones lo suficiente para que ocurra
una fusión para que ocurra una fusión
una emisión de fusión y cuando quiero
ser muy clara aquí no es que sea una
edición de combustión como lo conocemos
tradicionalmente como si quemaremos una
molécula de carbón no es combustión es
emisión y se llama así porque cuando
tenemos estos dos protones que se
fusionan
el núcleo resultante tiene una masa un
poquito más pequeña en la primera fase
de esto tenemos nuestros dos protones
tenemos estos dos protones que están lo
suficientemente cerca cuando hay presión
y temperatura suficiente como para que
las fuerzas fuertes interactúen y esto
se enganche y se mantengan juntos y uno
de estos protones se degrada en un
neutrón y la masa resultante de estos
protones combinados es menor que la masa
de los protones originales por un margen
muy pequeño pero ese pequeño margen de
masa que se pierde resulta en una gran
cantidad de energía y esta energía es a
lo que llamamos emisión lo que hace esta
emisión es proporcionar un poco de
presión externa para evitar que todo
esto siga colapsándose de manera que
esta presión externa va a ser
equivalente con la presión interna de lo
que ahora es una estrella ahora
tenemos la división en el centro
tenemos todas estas moléculas que tratan
de entrar proporcionando la presión
suficiente para que resulte esta emisión
de fusión y bueno y ahora en que se está
funcionando el hidrógeno en la primera
fase de esta reacción y ese es el tipo
de fusión más básico que puede ocurrir
en las estrellas el hidrógeno se fusiona
en deuterio que es una forma de decir
que es un hidrógeno pesado pues ya que
en el núcleo tiene un protón y un
neutrón esto todavía no es helio no
tiene dos protones todavía este núcleo
pero si el deuterio se sigue funcionando
eventualmente tendremos helio
y esto lo podemos ver en la tabla
periódica bueno déjenme encontrarla
primero se les mostraré en el siguiente
vídeo pero sabemos que el hidrógeno en
su estado atómico tiene el número
atómico de 1
y también tiene masa de uno sólo tiene
una partícula en el núcleo cuando se
fusionan se convierte en hidrógeno dos
deuterio que tiene un neutrón un protón
y por eso es que en su núcleo hay dos
partículas y esto cuando se fusiona
eventualmente nos va a dar helio y por
definición el helio tiene dos protones
dos neutrones tiene cuatro partículas en
el núcleo por lo que tiene una masa
atómica de cuatro y todo este proceso
libera una gran cantidad de energía ya
que la masa atómica del helio que se
produce es ligeramente más pequeña que
los cuatro protones de los átomos de
hidrógeno que tuvieron que fusionarse
para formar este helio
así que toda esta energía que viene de
la fusión originada por presiones muy
altas evita que la estrella continúe
colapsándose y una vez que la estrella
se encuentra en este estado en cuanto
está fusionando el hidrógeno en su
centro para convertirlo en helio se
encuentra en lo que se llama su
secuencia principal
esta es una estrella en secuencia
principal estrella en secuencia
principal y de hecho esta es la
secuencia en la que se encuentra nuestro
sol en este momento siempre surgen
preguntas de qué es lo que pasaría si no
se alcanza a lograr este punto de acá
incluso hay objetos que nunca llegan a
alcanzar oa superar el nivel necesario
para convertirse en estrellas de hecho
existen objetos más pequeños en donde
existe una gran presión y temperatura
pero no se logra dar la fusión un
ejemplo de esto podría ser el planeta
júpiter un objeto con varias veces la
masa de júpiter quizás podrían lograr
este nivel así pues es necesario
un límite en un exista la temperatura la
masa y la presión suficiente para lograr
este estado de fusión y mientras superen
por poco este límite más va a durar el
combustible en cambio si es supermasivo
el consumo de combustible va a ocurrir
muy rápido esta es la idea general de
cómo se forman las estrellas y por qué
no se colapsan en ellas mismas en otro
vídeo hablaremos qué es lo que sucede
cuando este helio que se encuentra en el
núcleo comienza a acabarse